[music]
Welcome to this course on the Past,
Present and Future of Fossil Fuels.
My name is Mark Zoback. I'm a Professor of Geophysics at Stanford University.
The context for this class is to understand the global energy and environment challenge.
By around 2050 we're going to
have to be providing something like nine
billion people twice as much energy as
we provide today.
This course is divided into three sections.
The first part of the course I referred to as the past.
The second part of the course is this major change
with the discovery that we could produce enormous amounts of gas and then oil
from what are called unconventional oil and gas reservoirs.
And the final part of the course really is looking to the future
examining what role natural gas is going to be playing
as this critical bridge fuel as we decarbonize the energy system.
[music]